الذي اذاقه امريكا ويلات
الاحتلال والحلف فرصته الوحيدة
هناك اقوى من التحالف الاسلامي
ان وفي حال تجمعت الدول التي
مستعدا لاستقبال عواصف وتحركات
وانقسامات وتحالفات جديدة. وهل
الامريكية الاخيرة المتعلقة
بزيادة انتاج النفط. واخرها كان
العلاقات بينها وبين تركيا
فستكون ايضا احدى الدول القوية
من ردع اسرائيل في فلسطين ووضع
حد لانتهاكاتها ولن تستطيع
فشلتا في كبح جماح روسيا والصين.
لذا لا بد وان يكون العالم
اسلامية. تحررت من الاحتلال
الامريكي الذي عبث فيها لعشرين
ليأخذ بثأره لمليون قتيل. الغرب
انتقل الى وضعية الدفاع وهو ما
يمكن انه يحدث للمرة الاولى منذ
قرون. ذلك ان امريكا واوروبا
مليون نسمة. ولا ننسى افغانستان
وان كانت غير عربية فهي دولة
ايضا من الدول التي ستنضم للحلف
ومن الشركاء الفاعلين بحكم قوتها
طيبة مع المملكة العربية
السعودية والامارات العربية
ستكون اول المنضمين للحلف
الاسلامي في مواجهة اعدائه
ذكرناها في حلف واحد سيكون هذا
الحلف قوة لا يستهان بها سيتمكن
الجزائر رفضت املاءات امريكا
للضغط على روسيا وعلى العكس من
اكانوا امريكان او غيرهم.
الجزائر دولة غنية بالغاز وستكون
الحلف الغني القوي. ويا له من
حلف سيجعل جميع دول العالم تلهث
لن تقف في معزل عن الحلف ايضا.
واما الامارات فقد رفضت الاوامر
كبير مؤخرا مع السعودية وسط
تحذير امريكي من هذا التقارب.
بالحلف. فهي الدولة العربية
الاكثر سكانا باكثر من مائة
رفدا قوي للحلف. وهناك قطر ايضا
احد اكبر مصدري الغاز في العالم
لانتقامها. الانتقام ليس رغبة
لافغانستان وحدها. هناك العراق
المالية المتكونة من غناها نفط.
اما ام الدنيا مصر وبعد تحسن
رفض ادانة روسيا في مجلس الامن
والامم المتحدة. وتعتبر الامارات
ذلك اثبتت حسن العلاقات مع موسكو
باللقاءات المباشرة. الجزائر
ان نرى ايران على الرغم من
علاقتها الاكثر تعقيدا مع
المنفتح على العالم باسره وليس
على المسلمين فقط. دول العربية.
شاباز شريف عقب توليه منصب يقول
ان بلاده وتركيا ترتبطان بروابط
التركي الباكستاني لانها تعلم ان
باكستان تمتلك جيشا قويا. هذا
وضعت تركيا كل اللوم على
الولايات المتحدة الامريكية التي
لتحالف السعودية وباكستان ليس
هناك اصدقاء دائمون ولا اعداء
تظهر كما اظهرت تركيا انفتاح
الحلف على دول العالم وعلى رأسها
اهمية بناء علاقات طيبة معها.
كما اكد اهمية امتلاك علاقات
تواجه مصيرها امام روسيا. وعجز
الولايات المتحدة ايضا في ادارة
المملكة فقد باتت الدولتان
اهتماما من اي وقت مضى ببناء
روسيا. هذا الانفتاح يقلق امريكا
اسرائيل فهي قلقة من التقارب
امتنعت عن تزويد انقرة بسلاح
دفاعي مماثل. وهناك فتحت تركيا
المتحدة. باكستان هي احدى الدول
الثلاث التي تشكل نواة للحلف
عاما. ورغبتها بالانتقام ستكون
قوية. وسيكون الحلف داعما مهما
ملفات خطيرة كايران وكوريا
الشمالية وتعاظم امر الصين في
دائمون بل مصالح دائمة وهذا هو
قانون السياسة. منفتح. بشراء
التي لا تترك حلفائها كما هي
امريكا. ايضا قريبة من الحلف
منظومة اس اربعمائة الروسية رغما
عن الولايات المتحدة والناتو
امريكا العبث في دولة من الحلف
وستقترب روسيا والصين اكثر من
الكثير. والتحالف مع واشنطن لا
يجلب الامان لكثير من الدول بحسب
واتضحت الرؤى اكثر فاكثر فان لم
يعد لديها ما تعطيه للعالم بنظر
علاقات ايجابية بينهما فهل يشكل
رابط الدين نواة لانضمام ايران
يقترب من بعض البلدان عندما
يحتاج اليها ثم يبتعد ثانية.
الدولة الاكثر اسهاما في الامن
الاوروبي. لكن الاتحاد الاوروبي
العلاقات وتطويرها بين تركيا
والسعودية وانضمام باكستان لذلك
لا واعتبر ان الصين تعد شريكا
لبلاده في السراء والضراء. واكد
بكين لن تكون الشريك الاقرب من
هذا التحالف فقط بل ان روسيا
بالسعودية حط الرئيس التركي
اردوغان ونظيره الباكستاني شريف
واحدة امرا لا تصوره. لكن في
قاعة الاستقبال بقصر جدة حاول
التحالف سيكون قريبا من العمل مع
الصين التي تقاربت علاقاتها بشكل
العالم اظهار المخفي من العلاقات
بين السعودية وباكستان بما يخص
مليارات دولار في بنك باكستان
المركزي للمساعدة في دعم
المشاريع النووية بينما تمضي
الدولتان بصمت في هذا المجال.
هذه اول زيارة خارجية له. وقد
تكون اهم زيارة خارجية له في
يظهر طي صفحة الماضي بين تركيا
والسعودية. فعلى مدى بضع سنوات
فالغرب واوروبا لم يعودوا حلفا
امنا للدول الاخرى. ولذلك فتحسين
حياته السياسية. والخلاصة فتعزيز
الاقتصادات والتجارة والاستثمار
كان الهدف الظاهر لكن ما خفي كان
اعظم. وسبق للسعودية ايداع ثلاثة
العالم. صار الجميع يبحث عن
مصلحته. بعد هذا كله ليس عجيبا
اخر التطورات في العالم. فبعد
ترك الولايات المتحدة لاوكرانيا
المصالح. خلال الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية تبلورة التحالفات
ارض السعودية الاول جاءت زيارته
العلاقات السيئة. والاخر كانت
جميع الدول الاسلامية. بداية
الغيث قطرة. وبعد سنوات من
القوي ايضا. وهناك لم تستطع ايضا
باكستان تضم مئات الملايين من
عن تحالف المستقبل. والحديث ليس
فقط عن تركيا والسعودية لكن ايضا
المسلمين فرض رأيها مع امتلاكها
السلاح النووي الذي لا تمتلكه
ماضية كان وجود الرئيس التركي
وولي العهد السعودي في غرفة
المركزية في العالم الاسلامي غير
العربية مثل تركيا وباكستان
هذه الاطراف جميعها في مكان واحد
وفي تحالف واتحدوا ضد الغرب
عراك دائما مع دول تربطها معها
روابط دينية لكن هذه الروابط لم
حفاوة الاستقبال والعناق الحار
بين اعداء الامس وحلفاء اليوم
تمنع ان يحاول كل طرف قيادة دفة
الدول الاسلامية. فتارة حاولت
قتيل بسبب التدخل الامريكي في
اراضيه. جميع هذه الدول تتحين
علاقات سياسية سيئة لانقرة مع
الرياض وتراجع علاقات باكستان
ايران هي الاخرى قريبة من الحلف
برابط الدين. ومصر اقرب مما هو
لبناء علاقات جيدة مع روسيا.
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني الجديد
وبداية تحالف اسلامي قد يجذب
الكثير من الدول حولها. تصالح
الايجابية التي طغت على مشهد
العلاقات السعودية مع الدول
فرصتها والتحالف هو الفرصة
الوحيدة للجميع. فماذا لو تجمعت
تركيا ذلك بموقعها الجغرافي
وصناعاتها العسكرية واقتصادها
ترى نفسها بلدا اساسيا للسلام
الاقليمي والعالمي. وترى انها
الغنية بالغاز ستجد في الحلف ما
تبحث عنه. والجزائر ستنضم ولاول
كلاهما الاشارة الى بداية جديدة.
وبداية الغيث قطرة. تركيا التي
متوقع. الامارات النفطية تتجه
لتغيير اتجاهاتها ايضا. قطر
وامريكا. ما الذي سيحدث عندها؟
تحالف اسلامي. عادت الاجواء
وايران لترسخ موقع الدول
الاسلامية مجددا كتحالف موثوق به
احتياطاتها من النقد الاجنبي.
لكن ماذا عن دعم المشاريع ينتظر
السعودية ذلك بقوة اقتصادها
واموالها ونفطها. وتارة تحاول
وهذا ما يفعلونه مع عدد من الدول
من بينها بحسب النظرة التركية.
للخروج بالعالم الاسلامي الى بر
الامان عن الغرب ظلت السعودية في
قبل سنوات استعرت الحرب الباردة
بينهما. حاول كل منهما طمس هوية
اليوم فالصورة ابلغ من الكلام.
استقبال حافل وعناق دافئ يتحدث
مرة برضا تام عن حلفائها. اما
العراق فسيرغب بالانتقام لمليون
المسلمتين في ارض المملكة لكن
مهلا يبدو ان الحلف سيكبر. فهناك
السعودية في غرفة واحدة امر
مستحيل ولا يمكن تصوره. اما
الاخر حتى كان العالم يرى ان
وجود الرئيس التركي وامير
عن الدولة الاسلامية النووية
باكستان حيث حل قادة الدولتين
افغانستان بعد تخلصها من عقدين
من العبث الامريكي في اراضيها.
وراءه.